[Musique]
joël dicaire bonjour bonjour très
content pour rencontrer très heureux
déclare merci êtes de passage au québec
je pense que vous aimez bien merci
j'aime beaucoup venir ici j'ai des liens
avec le québec jeu chacun des passagers
est important pour moi
retrouvez le public québécois c'est
particulier je viens on vient de tourner
une série télé une adaptation de la
terreur et qu'albert donc j'étais
passablement ici à temps vous devez
payer un peu moins de juillet et le mois
de décembre
donc me revoilà avec beaucoup de bonheur
pour les téléspectateurs
téléspectatrices qui me connaissent un
peu moins spécifiant que votre livre la
vérité sur la sphère éric hébert s'est
vendu à 4 millions d'exemplaires
vous avez aujourd'hui 32 ans comment on
vit avec tout ce succès mais vous savez
je crois que le succès d'un livre un
succès très différent de ce qu'on
considère le succès aujourd'hui qu'on
pourrait imaginer le succès d'un acteur
ou d'art musiciens parce que le succès
c'est le livre les gens ont lu le livre
et vous savez c'est amusant parce que
beaucoup de gens ne me connaissent pas
beaucoup de gens connaissent pas à nîmes
au visage ni mon âge par exemple vous
avez pas parlé de mon âge mais je
rencontre souvent des lecteurs qui
disent mais vous êtes jeune vous n'êtes
pas un vieux et est donc moi j'ai un
rapport très distant avec le succès
parce que j'ai écrit ce roman j'ai écrit
six romans tout seul le prochain roman
de nouveau je vais me remettre au
travail à ma table de travail chez moi à
genève tout seul nokia une grande
distance entre la perception que les
gens peuvent avoir imaginé le succès qui
est un succès de chiffres et de vente
est assez fou et ma réalité du succès
qui est très intense et profond
vos intrigues sont parfois compliquées
et plusieurs vous demande est-ce que
vous avez un plan pour organiser tout ça
quand ça fonctionne sur votre table de
travail
il n'y a pas de plan je fais jamais de
plan histoire et sans plan je sais pas
ce qui va se passer dans le roman je le
découvre au fur et à mesure que je
l'écris était très important pour moi je
le dis pas comme une promesse
pas du tout je le raconte pas ce que ça
explique pourquoi le roman ou l'hérault
- sont si denses
autant de personnages autant de
rebondissements parce que je sais que si
je faisais un plan avant me disant voilà
le début le milieu et la fin et que je
calibre est le nombre de rebondissements
et le nombre de personnages les romands
seraient moitié moins gros parce que je
me dirai ça suffit ici et donc c'est
parce que justement j'ai pas de plan et
que je ne sais pas où je vais que je me
nourris du plaisir que je crois que tant
que j'ai du plaisir à écrire un roman
ça veut dire que je suis sur la bonne
piste parce qu'on veut pas savoir si le
roman sera un succès ou pas il n'y a pas
de recette pour écrire un roman qu'est
le succès s'il y avait une recette tous
les romanciers ya beaucoup de succès
tous les éditeurs sont très contents
je crois que le seul secret c'est avoir
du plaisir quand on écrit son contenu
vous revenez avec un quatrième livre
intitulé la disparition de stéphanie
mahler star roman policier
mais vous vous dites là c'est pas un
roman policier explications j'explique
c'est un roman dans lequel il ya une
enquête policière est donc qu'il ya un
côté policier pour son enquête mais
c'est aussi un roman à propos de toute
une galerie de personnages une trentaine
qui raconte un petit bout de leur vie à
ce moment là leur vie à côté de l'
enquête et je vous précise ça parce que
il ya un ou deux personnages qui sont
importants pour moi
romancier j'avais envie de raconter ces
personnages là qui n'ont pas forcément
un lien direct avec l'en quête qui fait
partie du livre aussi aider des lecteurs
vont écrire me disant mais ça va pas tel
père ce personnage n'a pas de lien avec
le crime il enquête
c'est une arnaque et je dis maintenant
ce n'est pas une arnaque parce que c'est
pas un roman policier complètement
oui il ya un côté policier mais je dis
pas complètement parce que j'ose même
pas ce que c'est pour dire aux gens
attention tout ne tourne pas autour de
l' enquête il ya aussi autre chose
page 3 157 de ce roman un de vos
personnages dit que les rapports juste
un sous genre
parce que c'est votre avis non pas du
tout il ya un des personnages dans le
livre qui dit ça qui est un critique et
qu'ils adoreraient écrire un roman pour
les policiers mais ils expliquent le
rebond plus important c'est celui auquel
on comprend rien et c'est de faire pas
du tout je raconte cette petite scène je
me 7,7 pour dire arrêtons de me créer
des barrières entre les gens lisez des
livres
lisez ce qui vous plaît partager les
livres offrez vous des livres aller chez
le libraire pas sur internet mais
partager le plaisir des livres sans se
poser de question de se dire est ce que
c'est de la littérature ou pas de la
littérature est ce que c'est bien ou pas
lisons c'est tellement important juin 10
cas jusqu'au bout il parlera votre
prochain roman
mais j'en sais rien parce que j'ai pas
de plan justement et que c'est ça le
plaisir c'est que j'ai aucune idée et
que je me laisse guider par une envie
par une intuition que il ya des idées
qui amène vers d'autres idées et que ces
poupons pour moi c'est important de ne
pas avoir de plan parce que comme ça
j'ai une liberté totale et je vais pas
me bloquer dans une direction me disant
enfin parler de ça je verrai bien si
affinités